hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to papers please please
put in the comments your papers that
show that you're allowed to be here
along with your work permit your travel
visa your passport all your information
don't actually put your information in
the comments
or do don't actually don't but
in this hypothetical scenario do don't
don't actually what have i done could
all no don't cut
but do but don't ah i'll leave it to you
elixir whatever legal ramifications
happen to me
or on your shoulders okay it's all on
you buddy
it's all on you i trust you
and all legal ramifications are on
lixie's shoulders
okay cool thanks sorry excuse me okay
excuse me i gotta record a video
ah anyway let's walk to work
i gotta make some money my my family is
uh in the cold and that's probably not
good
uh to facilitate more thorough
inspections a search scanner has been
installed glitching extremists are
suspected in yesterday's bombing
kalechian okay kalechian search all
collections before approving their entry
all right this seems rather biased but
okay
correlate pertinent entry rulebook with
violations for further
options okay so i need to like have
these rules
up and ready to go and i got to make
some money so let's go
hi kalechia hi y'all here we go okay all
right here we go
uh let's see
kolechia kalechia excuse me you have
been selected for a random search
hmm
is it taking a while okay thankfully no
nudity
all right so you're good you can keep
that what was he need
oh i probably should have checked the
actual dates and stuff before
okay kelechi of the door vladinic visit
no work this is great oddly enough
you're good to go
you want that okay never mind oh this is
gonna take forever this is gonna take
absolutely forever if we have to do all
this
nonsense oh my god kalechia
while you're doing that i'm gonna check
all this that's a good that's good use
of time okay cletchio west
grested why's everyone got to be from
kalechia okay what do we got okay good
any weapons on you oh god damn it oh god
damn it no
oh my god oh my god my family's gonna
starve
what's this what is this you've made a
mistake coming here is it so obvious
well i mean kind of what is this what if
they have a bomb and they just blow it
up in the middle of my booth
hello transit
okay remember match is up expiration's
good
justin go okay this looks good
all looks good here thank you have a
lovely day
i didn't check the actual oh oh
god damn it the photo the photo
oh i have to search you oh okay
all right let's take the name photo's
good
expiration's good your go yeah that's
oh my god it's so much that i have to
check
okay let's see let's see let's see all
right okay
oh oh my god what no god why do you have
to do this to me
why do you have to do this shouldn't i
get a bonus for actually finding people
with contraband
you know nothing slow down my friend
i've only harmless oh
no i would've
extra money oh oh that sounded pretty
good oh
god damn it god damn it
oh my god just please
okay bye-bye search uh
expiration's good expression good year
goes i know that's good
uh all right this seems all good
oh my god a wapoon you made a mistake
coming here
you know nothing too bad you know
nothing you go you go nothing nowhere
move okay number's fine expressions good
expressions good issues shingleton
yep that's good name's good picture's
good all looks good
love it this is great love it love it
have a good day have a good day have a
good day more money more money more what
no what invalid names
oh okay you're good to go buddy you're
good to go
invalid name invalid name
this is so stressful it's so goddamn
stressful
everything oh my god why so many
freaking kalechians
oh my god with the kalechians yurko i
know that city's good expiration's good
all this is good give me my work
penalties here
oh please
okay you're good to go buddy you're good
to go thank you pal
have a good day pal have a good day have
a good day pal
give me one more pal give me one more
give me one more so i can make some
delicious money so i can feed my family
paper oh my god another kalechian
that's fantastic
okay you're good to go congratulations
you win
have fun
[Music]
so
wow very tough hey let's keep going
my family's going to be fine collection
leader files complaint
claims unprovoked border searchers
violate rights
that they do that they definitely do
wait what you gonna do what are you
doing what are you gonna do
it's just a little looking at people's
nakedness
just looking it's a little invasion of
privacy for safety whatever okay a
diplomat will arrive for high-level
discussions automatic searches of
collection citizens are no longer
authorized diplomats require only a
passport and a valid diplomatic
authorization
referred to rulebook for updated
documentation information
okay diplomats oh
the diplomatic seals that's what that's
about
okay so i need the absolute perfect
diplomatic seals
all right this is where this comes into
play but i have it in my cheat sheet
now i can fly by get ready give me give
me give me
okay okay the seal is is super good
number max is up everything's good here
diplomat is good
bam you got it get out of here go go go
go go go go
perfect nailed it everything's great i'm
the best
this is easy this is easy now hey what's
up buddy
oh wow um
okay uh well you know unfortunately you
need
more than that you're nice guy but i
have a business our associate i get the
right person come see you okay you'll
get it eventually buddy but you can't be
here now
[Music]
hi how are you doing oh good
oh great great man thank you for this
this good stuff hey what's up how you
doing
okay it's good that's good this is
good great rapid is good good
all this is good this seems good this
seems good real good real good real good
stuff
good stuff thank you thank you for
having everything in order
hello you're lucky i'm not inspecting
you you're
lucky 90 days that's good number matches
name matches kalechia or ecuador i know
that
whoa wait a minute no it's not kalechia
is not orek venor
you get out of here this is wrong oh you
could pull a fast one on me you could
not
you absolutely couldn't i probably would
get like offers of
bribes more if i actually confronted
them with information
maybe i should start doing that this
looks good thank you have a good day
yeah maybe if i should actually confront
people maybe they would
offer me money i mean if they could
offer me money more than what i'm
actually doing
i wouldn't mind taking it well where's
your where's your uh
where's your uh oh ah
goddammit where's the uh
uh do you have your card
well too bad buddy you need it could
offer me a bribe i would have been very
acceptable to that but you didn't
name an
antegria st marmaro
all looks good all looks good you have a
lovely day you have a lovely day you
take care of yourself
one more please one more thank you oh oh
wait
no come on in no come in no no no what a
good day
what a good day oh i could tab oh
look at my mons oh mons
mons i can afford a tab upgrade
yes that will save me so much time
that is actually i mean i'm not gonna
lie that
that's pretty good top level kalechian
exposed says arstotzkan spy
missing from post presumed dead well
that's not me
so i guess i'm okay so far so good i
mean i'm getting better at my job
i'm able to actually do things i don't
know what that's for okay inspector
an undercover agent of the ministry of
information has been compromised
ministry of admission has offered its
services as liaison expect a possible
drop later today
drop of what okay tab that that is very
helpful
these are very helpful tools but my food
is here so i'm going to pause recording
and then i'm gonna come back in a bit
okay i'm back all right so i don't know
what the diplomat like drop off is gonna
be or the other thing but
all i need to know is that i have tab
now i have a space
and i'm gonna make some money
[Music]
i'm guard here my name is kalensk they
told me i get good position then send me
here
this is thanks i get now they pay me
almost nothing
they pay us all as much whatever
yes but look i get small bonus when you
detain people
the more you detain more they give me
for processing
but this is not fair right you should
get something too so i fix this problem
i give you five credits for my bonus for
every two people you detain
sounds like good deal to me i give you
money to you after i get paid
let us make the best of this
okay hey man i'm down to clown with that
as long as we're detaining criminals
here it's all good it's all good hey
it's all good
hi hello purpose of visit
transiting dates good uh this picture
doesn't match up hey buddy what's going
on here
this does not look like you you had
surgery
no way give this here peter
okay let's see oh do i actually have to
match this oh my god
okay yeah this match is okay fine
fine you're good but i want to detain
you i wanted to
because surgery whatever the surgery my
ass
transit dates good dates good republia
true glory two days austin tiltova
looking good i really want to detain you
wait a minute nope
deny deny deny deny
deny denied get out of here
i saw that mismatching passport number i
saw that i could have detained you
but i didn't i have not much time
i must hold on to this oh it's the
drop-off keep them safe today
i'm being followed by an imposter okay
they pretend to be from the ministry of
information but it is a lie if they ask
for documents give them these instead
oh god okay
these are the good this is the what it
oh
which one okay give them this one this
is the keeper keeper give
keep no keep give
never going to confuse those
you got a passport buddy what is
passport okay well all right
what is a passport i can't help you
you're lucky i don't detain you get out
of here get out of here
do you get this give keep keep going i
think i got it right
i hope i've got it how are you doing
okay wow
i'm from the ministry of information you
have something to give us
okay thanks here there you go
i hope i gave you the right one thanks
for the money
i like money okay picture matches up
60 kilograms 170 yeah it's about right
here kind of
cuts off a little bit birthday matches
up oreck vanor that's
good the shiloh ah
you know looking all good i don't see it
i don't see any problems with this looks
good
hey have a good welcome home what
you have something in my what
[Music]
what this
great country points microwave wars
maybe help us free us
okay cool do not lose this oh
god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god i don't know what that is oh
my god okay
work let's see
a few weeks yeah well it's not
technically a month but the date's fine
this matches up let's see impor sukendo
carl kalis food service that's good
all this matches up okay you look good
to me
get out of here have a good one take
care of yourselves cause no trouble
have a good day but
wait in validation buddy with girl
galore car calendar
carl columbu
the hell is wrong with carl 176 50. wow
what is this well you got some money you
got some on you there's a discrepancy
detected hey what's up what's up with
your weight you got a four kilograms of
explosives strapped to your butt
oh you do have four kilograms of
explosie
um well that's a problem
you made a mistake what could it be the
you know explodies on your back could it
be the esplodies
if i get another detainee i can i can
make more money
let's see
wait work wait did you say work you just
said work
what's up with that you're just visiting
huh
well everything else is in order
antegria
saint marmaro jessica
i mean everything does kind of match up
but you did say the wrong thing but i'm
feeling nice so
whatever there you go have a good day
applicants entering after 6 p.m are
unpaid
okay hey but i got a bribe
i did get a bribe that's good stuff
[Music]
kalechian cleans house eliminates
arstotzkan spies heroic agents
compromised did i give them the right
paperwork
uh did i do ah did i do the right one
i do not know if i actually did the
right one there whatever it's all
dust in the wind after all it's all just
oh what's that what is what is this
the divisional authority of east crest
and operation will visit today
maintain your best behavior okay
uh it's not my fault by the way that
that happened woody
hello are you are you here to uh talk to
me about the whole
spy incident
oh hi so
you're our inspector yes i am your
english very good
that makes you my responsibility you
have received 18 citations perhaps it
was mistake to lie on
pottery let's this motivate you
hanging on wall here i return in 10 days
recognition for sufficience i've had 18
violations
18 good god all right hey but i'm
sufficient all right that's okay with me
i'm gonna hang that on the wall
all right let's get this party trainer
moving
come on in buddy hey what's up hey pal
how you doing give me your papers
uh well you know you don't have anything
so get out of here easy money baby
easy money what's up hey how you doing
um where's your passport
what's his passport okay that's well
we're just at a non-starter here if you
don't even know
no i'm not leaving
all right well you will be leaving you
refuse you fools better not touch me
i will explode like wild tyke have a
right to enter
[Music]
poor lady oh boy okay well
you know maybe you shouldn't have uh
exploded like wild
tiger hey what's up our agents are ready
starting tomorrow oh
all right okay stephanie grier
and michali sarrodova
saratov okay stefanie and sarkovy
okay whatever produced yeah fur
for ferdesto ferdesto i've got
fardesk though hang on i gotta look this
up for fur
[Applause]
oh well too bad buddy you're getting
detained
boom detained get detained
you're not pulling a fast one on me with
that ferdesto
okay joanie a diplomat
this looks good this looks good man this
looks really good
this looks great uh from murderous huh
yeah oh
this looks good yeah this is great man
hey thank you
take care buddy stefani and what no
diplomatic
oh was that was that a thing
was that a thing no diplomat was that a
thing
oh no looks good to me
i sure am sufficient you are very tall
by the way see
transit number's good marry the sunday
date is good outer groose that's good
this is all good
looks good to me buddy looks good to me
if i'm wrong i'm an
looks like i'm not an oh denied
denied not oh i got it i got it i got
that one in i got that one in
that one got in did it get in
yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes i'm the best theft at the
ministry of admission limited effects
for adam sold
integria domestic spying expose
whistleblower on the one
so how does this affect my day-to-day
life by the way
oh a break-in at the moa offices may
have compromised our document sealing
plates
nothing important was stolen but
intelligence suggests counterfeiters
have already begun forging
official or skin documents continued
double check that required documents
contain
valid valid seals
correlate missing or wrong seals against
the appropriate entries in the documents
chapter of your rule book
okay so i have to check for actual seals
now
okay cool and i still have to look for
steph
stefani stephanie grier and mchale
saratov let's do this looking for valid
seals now i gotta get everything
super pristine hello
okay carmen okay all the dates match up
let me just double check
this is actually like the valid seal
republia
republia valdez seals okay
is that quite right oh that was wrong
this is a forgery
you don't know anything about that well
it's a forgery
it wasn't perfectly circular it was kind
of oblong so there was something about
that
okay well that's money for me hi look at
you
hello my guy oh look at all these papers
holy crap look at this it's you
what the hell oberston from skull what
the heck and heck
all of this is good holy crap dude
my guy what the heck
[Music]
huh
oh hi what what's the deal
you detained four people i sure did
bonus is good they pay okay this is not
enough
my wife is sick now neighbor spreads the
flu
this is what's left after medicine i
give you the rest next time
maybe you detain more people to make it
easier
well it's not exactly an option that
just pops up my dude it's not exactly an
option that just
pops up not what i was promised
hello and i still have to look for
mchale
saratov
get out of here
the order knows oh
oh no
oh no was that a dude
oh did i screw oh god oh
nudity on
ass my
i have an idea everybody okay i'm gonna
end this episode here
on this dramatic conclusion because i i
think if i
alt f4 out of it you know if i like end
task from the task manager maybe
it won't save that and then i can go
back in again and maybe
correct my mistake if that was a mistake
but it's probably a mistake okay
i'm thinking that maybe that'll be it
but we'll see in the next episode if
that actually is something that i can do
remember your papers everybody don't
leave them at home
don't be there without them always take
care
have your papers ready and if a little
forgery is needed eh
[Music]
bye